A quick warning-- there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of the show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
友情提示，本期节目中含有未经消音的脏话。如果您更倾向于收听消音版本，请前往我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org。
We're all getting kind of old in my family. And when we get together for the holidays, there's never any drama anymore. Used to be. I avoided coming home for years all through my 20s and early 30s because my parents and I were not getting along so well. Part of the problem was me. In my early 20s, I was harsh and judgey and said lots of things that now I wouldn't have said and have apologized for.
我们家的人都渐渐老了。每逢节日聚在一起时，再也不会有什么矛盾了。以前可不是这样。我20多岁到30出头的那几年，为了避开回家，整整躲了几年，因为我和父母的关系实在不和。部分原因在我。我20岁出头时，为人尖刻且爱评判他人，说了许多现在绝不会再说、事后也道过歉的话。
But part of the problem was them. They did not agree with most of my big life choices, starting with and especially the fact that I worked in public radio. During that period, I was working for the NPR news shows, All Things Considered and Morning Edition. And my parents were completely against it. I've said this before-- and my parents hate it when I say this-- but my parents are the only Jews in America who don't like public radio.
但部分原因也在他们。他们不同意我人生中的大部分重大选择，首当其冲且尤其不满的一点是，我在公共广播电台工作。那段时间，我为美国国家公共电台（NPR）的《纵观全局》（All Things Considered）和《早间新闻》（Morning Edition）节目工作。我的父母对此极力反对。我以前说过——而且我父母很讨厌我这么说——但我父母大概是美国仅有的不喜欢公共广播的犹太人了。
The stories are too long. It seemed second rate to them. If I wanted to be a journalist, why wasn't I on TV? Why was I settling for this place that paid me so little? The money was a huge thing. My dad is an accountant, does all our taxes, and so he knew what I made and couldn't quite believe it. I could still earn a good living somewhere. I could still be a doctor.
他们觉得故事太长。在他们看来，这属于二流水平。如果我想当记者，为什么不上电视？为什么要在这样一个薪水微薄的地方委屈求全？钱是个大问题。我父亲是会计，负责我们全家的报税，所以他清楚我的收入，并对此感到难以置信。我本可以在别处挣得体面的生活。我本可以成为一名医生。
So coming home for the holidays, sometimes my dad would pull me aside. Sometimes he would bring it up during dinner at a crowded table. Shouldn't I quit these jobs I love and finally go to med school? It's not too late, my parents pleaded with me well into my 30s. My mom officially, kind of half joking, half serious, gave up the effort when I was 41 and had been hosting This American Life for five years.
所以每逢节日回家，我父亲有时会把我拉到一边，有时会在挤满人的餐桌上提起这件事。他不该让我辞掉这些我热爱的工作，去读医学院吗？我的父母一直劝我，哪怕到了30多岁还是这样。直到我41岁，并且已经主持《美国生活》（This American Life）节目五年时，我母亲才半开玩笑半认真地放弃了劝说。
But for so long, my dad especially would express his love and concern for me when I came home by questioning the basics-- where I lived, how I lived, how I dressed, how my hair looked, who I fell in love with, why wasn't I more of a success. To be clear, he wasn't mean. He wasn't angry. He was just very, very concerned.
但在很长一段时间里，我回家时，我父亲表达关爱和担忧的方式，尤其倾向于质疑我生活的基本面——我住哪儿，怎么住，穿什么，头发什么样，爱上谁，为什么没能取得更大的成就。明确地说，他并不是坏，也不是愤怒。他只是非常、非常地忧心。
My sisters, Randi and Karen, they got their own versions of this. So holidays, yeah, things would get very tense. Which is to say, we were a normal family. But now, it couldn't be more different. My mom died over a decade ago. My dad's in his 80s. In the last couple years, he's had a lot of hearing loss. It's harder to interact with him. He is not the critical, questioning man he once was.
我的姐妹们，兰迪和凯伦，也经历过类似的事情。所以假期里，气氛确实会变得非常紧张。也就是说，我们是一个正常的家庭。但现在，情况完全不同了。我母亲在十多年前去世了。我父亲现在80多岁了。过去几年里，他的听力严重下降。与他交流变得更难了。他不再是曾经那个爱批判、爱质疑的人了。
I go home now, and nothing's bothering him about me that he needs to get off his chest. He's been trained over the years to say I love you when we talk on the phone or see each other. And he actually seems to mean it. He's lovely. But I am not used to this milder, gentler version of the overworked, stressed out dad that I grew up with. It's like that guy-- I don't know-- dissolved away that whole side of his personality, leaving another man standing there.
我现在回家，他不再对我有什么不满，也不需要把什么事憋在心里。这些年来，他已经习惯了在电话里或见面时说“我爱你”。而且他看起来是真心的。他很可爱。但我还不习惯眼前这个温和、谦逊的版本，这和我从小到大那个工作过度、压力山大的父亲完全不同。就好像那个家伙——不知道——他那部分个性彻底消失了，只剩下眼前这个新人。
And I have to say-- this is bad to admit-- sometimes I miss that other guy. I go home for the holidays, and it's chill and everybody gets along. And I never thought I'd say this-- I swear I never thought these words would come out of my mouth-- I wish he would pick a fight with me. I feel like that's my real dad.
而且我不得不说——承认这一点不太好——有时我会怀念那个老家伙。我回家过节，气氛很轻松，大家都能和睦相处。我从没想过我会说这种话——我发誓我从没想过这些话会从我口中说出——但我希望他能和我吵一架。我觉得那才是真正的我父亲。
This elderly guy with the same name, who likes and accepts the person that I'm in love with and, in fact, notices if she leaves her glasses in the dining room and then helpfully brings them to her in the kitchen just to be nice, that guy, he's awesome. But where's my real dad? And this BS of going home for the holidays and not having anything to fight about at all, I mean, are our lives over? Are we already dead? That's it? We're done? No fighting? Are we really a family anymore?
眼前这位同名的老先生，他喜欢并接纳我爱的人，事实上，他还会留意到她把眼镜落在餐厅，然后体贴地把眼镜送到厨房，仅仅是因为好心，这位老先生很棒。但真正的父亲去哪儿了？回家过节却完全没什么可吵的，这简直是瞎扯，我是说，我们的人生结束了吗？我们已经死了吗？就这样？我们完了？没有争吵？我们还算是一个家庭吗？
Today, on our program, we have families boisterously, noisily getting into it with each other, kids coming home with important stuff they've been waiting to get off their chests, parents showing up at their grown children's houses with demands that absolutely need to be met, and then let the games begin. For the holidays, it is a family get-together episode of our show, including a song sung at a family event that either is or is not a veiled critique of one family member in particular. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天，在我们的节目中，我们将看到一些家庭吵吵闹闹、大声争执的场面：孩子们带着憋在心里已久的重任回家，父母带着绝对需要被满足的要求出现在成年子女家中，然后，游戏开始了。在这个节日里，这是一期家庭团聚主题的节目，其中包括在家庭聚会上演唱的一首歌，这首歌要么是对某位家庭成员含蓄的批评，要么根本不是。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, How Do I Say This? So we begin today with somebody returning to their family in the suburbs out in the far west in Canada, in Calgary, Alberta. And she is returning with a mission, something she needed to discuss in English, though the thing she wanted to discuss was a different language entirely. The person doing this is Scaachi Koul.
第一幕，我该怎么说？节目开头，我们先来看一位回到加拿大最西端——阿尔伯塔省卡尔加里——郊区家中的人。她带着一个任务回来，有些话她必须用英语沟通，尽管她想谈论的事情完全属于另一种语言。讲述这件事的人是斯卡奇·考尔。
Nine months ago, after 28 years of being alive, I finally started taking Hindi classes. My parents are both from India, and they emigrated to Canada long before I was born. They speak a number of languages, including Hindi, and their mother tongue, Kashmiri. But there's no real textbook or organized class or Duolingo program for Kashmiri. Hindi proved to be the easiest one for me to learn.
九个月前，在我活了28年之后，我终于开始上印地语课了。我的父母都来自印度，在我出生前很久就移民到了加拿大。他们会说多种语言，包括印地语和他们的母语克什米尔语。但市面上没有针对克什米尔语的真正的教科书、有组织的课程或多邻国程序。印地语被证明是我最容易学习的一门语言。
I'm not enjoying these lessons. I've said aloud in class several times that I hate it. I hate it because it's hard, harder than I expected. Because for some reason, I thought this language would come naturally. And yet, for two hours every week, I meet my teacher and fellow classmate at a coffee shop in midtown Manhattan and learn how to greet someone, and tell them what I am presently eating, and that the cat is sitting in the big chair. Sometimes the cat is sitting on the little chair. Learning to say that has cost me $1,150 thus far.
我不享受这些课程。我在课堂上好几次大声说我不喜欢它。我讨厌它是因为它太难了，比我预想的要难。因为出于某种原因，我以为这种语言我会无师自通。然而，每周有两个小时，我都会在曼哈顿市中心的一家咖啡店见到我的老师和同学，学习如何向别人打招呼，告诉他们我正在吃什么，以及猫正坐在大椅子上。有时猫坐在小椅子上。到目前为止，学说这些话已经花了我1150美元。
I started these lessons on a whim. I knew for years that I wanted to do it, but I didn't give much thought as to why. I assumed my parents would be happy about it. Not even just happy-- elated. My dad has said to me more than once, you're barely recognizable. When he says it, he means I'm not recognizable to him as the person he wanted me to be, the person who would never, for example, have married a white man much older than she is, or refused a career in medicine, or smoked at least 800 cigarettes.
我一时兴起开始了这些课程。多年来我一直知道我想做这件事，但我没怎么考虑原因。我以为我的父母会很高兴。甚至不仅仅是高兴，而是欣喜若狂。我父亲不止一次对我说：“你几乎让人认不出来了。”当他说这句话时，他的意思是，他认不出我就是他希望我成为的那个人，那个永远不会嫁给比她大很多岁的白人，不会拒绝医学职业，或者不会抽掉至少800支香烟的人。
But I don't know if my learning Hindi even matters to my parents, or how much. I also don't know why they never made me learn it in the first place. So I went home to find out.
但我不知道我学习印地语对我的父母来说是否重要，或者有多重要。我也不知道为什么他们当初从来没有让我学习它。所以我回家去一探究竟。
Hey, Google. Play something by Girija Devi.
嘿，谷歌。播放吉里贾·戴维的歌。
Here's a Spotify station featuring [INAUDIBLE] Devi.
这里有一个收录了[听不清]·戴维作品的Spotify电台。
When I visit my parents, we don't usually do much more than sit together in the living room and alternate between joking and fighting. We're all indoor cats.
我去探望父母时，我们通常做的事情无非就是坐在客厅里，在开玩笑和吵架之间来回切换。我们都是居家猫。
Hey, Google.
嘿，谷歌。
I recently got them a Google Home, foolishly thinking they'd delight in being able to boss it around. They've had it for a day and have been characteristically hostile to it.
我最近给他们买了一个Google Home智能音箱，傻傻地以为他们会喜欢指使它干活。他们用了才一天，表现得一如既往地充满敌意。
Hey, Google. No, that's wrong.
嘿，谷歌。不对，那是错的。
Sorry, I might be a little buggy.
抱歉，我可能有点故障。
Yeah, you are buzzy.
是啊，你是有故障（buzzy，谐音）。
She didn't say she was buzzy. She said she was buggy.
她没说她有故障（buzzy），她说她有故障（buggy）。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
Like, she has a bug.
就像是她出了个程序错误（bug）。
My parents have long converted my childhood bedroom into a sorry storage facility, but it's still home. There's nothing more comforting to me than my mom accusing an inanimate object of being against her.
我的父母早就把我的童年卧室变成了可怜的储藏室，但那依然是我的家。对我来说，没有什么比听我母亲指责一件无生命物体在和她作对更让我感到慰藉的了。
This thing is a racist because I keep telling play bhajan, and it doesn't play bhajan.
这东西是个种族主义者，因为我一直让它播放敬神歌曲（bhajan），它就是不播。
When the Google Home fails to play the devotional song my mom requests, she curses at it. And I finally recognize one of the few Kashmiri words I know from my childhood.
当Google Home无法播放母亲要求的敬神歌曲时，她便咒骂它。我终于认出了童年记忆中为数不多的几个克什米尔语词汇之一。
[KASHMIRI]
[克什米尔语]
What'd she say?
她说的是什么？
[KASHMIRI], as my mom said, is her saying that she hopes lightning hits the Google Home. The insults my parents use are the part of their language I absolutely know. I can help you call someone lazy, dumb, loud, annoying, rude, ugly. But the one I know best is [KASHMIRI]. You say it when you're mad or shocked or when someone's cooking is so excellent, you just can't help but want them to get hit by lightning. My dad eventually gives up on trying to teach the Google Home Kashmiri and settles on something she knows.
[克什米尔语]，就像我母亲说的那样，这是在说她希望闪电劈中这个Google Home。我父母用的辱骂词汇是我唯一完全听懂的语言。我可以帮你骂人懒惰、愚蠢、吵闹、烦人、无礼、丑陋。但我最熟的一个词是[克什米尔语]。当你生气、震惊，或者某人做的菜实在太好吃，让你忍不住希望他们被雷劈时，你就会说这个词。我父亲最终放弃了教Google Home克什米尔语，选择了她熟悉的东西。
Hey, Google. Play Frank Sinatra. You have to say please to her?
嘿，谷歌。播放弗兰克·辛纳屈的歌。你得跟她说“请”吗？
No, she's a robot. I mean, it's nice, but it's not necessary.
不，她是个机器人。我是说，这样有礼貌，但不是必须的。
[MUSIC - "COME FLY WITH ME" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐 - 弗兰克·辛纳屈的《跟我飞翔》]
That's my main man, isn't he? I should have a cigarette and a whiskey in one hand and a smoking jacket.
那可是我的头号偶像，对吧？我该一手拿着香烟和威士忌，身上披着吸烟装。
It's 10:00 in the morning.
现在是早上10点。
Who cares? It's 10:00 PM somewhere.
谁在乎？别处已经是晚上10点了。
Later that night, my mom hosts a party for my brother's 40th birthday. And she's cooked her usual dinner party spread-- the mallu, rogan josh, bhatta, haakh dripping in oil.
那天晚些时候，我母亲为我哥哥的40岁生日举办了派对。她做了惯常的聚餐菜肴——马鲁（mallu）、罗根乔什（rogan josh）、巴塔（bhatta）、滴着油的哈克（haakh）。
Happy birthday.
生日快乐。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I have all these questions for my parents. But first, I want to talk to my brother, the only other person in the world who understands what I'm getting myself into. I call my brother 'Bhai,' meaning older brother. He's 12 years older than me and was born in India. Kashmiri is his first language, and though he understands it when it's spoken to him, he lost the ability to speak it himself soon after he moved to Canada as a toddler. He doesn't remember anyone trying to get him to speak Kashmiri instead of English.
我有好多问题想问父母。但首先，我想和哥哥聊聊，他是世界上唯一理解我正在做什么的人。我称呼哥哥为“Bhai”，意思是哥哥。他比我大12岁，在印度出生。克什米尔语是他的第一语言，虽然他能听懂，但在以幼童身份移居加拿大后不久，他就失去了说这门语言的能力。他不记得有任何人试图让他说克什米尔语而不是英语。
But nobody said anything to me, or maybe they did, and I just said, I just want to watch Three's Company. Thank you very much.
但没有人跟我说过什么，或者也许他们说过，而我只是说，我只想看《三人行》（Three's Company）。非常感谢。
That is how my brother learned English-- reruns of Three's Company. Consequently, he has a very complex understanding of tenant protection rights. My brother affirms one thing I remember to be true when we were kids. It was deeply uncool to speak Hindi or Kashmiri. We knew lots of Indian kids who spoke their parents' language. They were dutiful, good, polite, always saying, yes, Auntie [INAUDIBLE]. But we also knew that those kids were fucking dorks and worthy of our ire. We were never dutiful.
这就是我哥哥学习英语的方式——看《三人行》的重播。因此，他拥有对租客保护权利非常复杂的理解。我哥哥证实了一件我记得小时候是真的事。说印地语或克什米尔语是极其不酷的行为。我们认识很多说父母母语的印度孩子。他们恭顺、乖巧、有礼貌，总是说着“是的，阿姨[听不清]”。但我们也知道，那些孩子是该死的书呆子，只配得上我们的鄙视。我们从来都不是恭顺的孩子。
Back then, I envied my brother. He's fair-skinned with angular features and a phonetic name. He could always hide in plain sight. I used to wish I could do the same.
那时候，我羡慕我的哥哥。他皮肤白皙，五官棱角分明，名字也很容易发音。他总是能轻易地隐藏在人群中。我曾经希望我也能这样。
My brother is married. He lives 20 minutes away from my parents. And he has a nine-year-old daughter that I call Raisin. She is the best person in the world. Raisin is biracial. Her mother is white, and she's light skinned with bright blue eyes. She doesn't speak Hindi or Kashmiri, with the exception of naming her favorite foods. And even though my brother could do something about her slim language skills, he hasn't.
我哥哥结婚了。他住在离我父母20分钟路程的地方。他有一个9岁的女儿，我叫她“葡萄干”（Raisin）。她是世界上最好的人。葡萄干是混血儿。她母亲是白人，她皮肤白皙，长着明亮的蓝眼睛。除了能说出她最爱吃的食物之外，她不会说印地语或克什米尔语。尽管我哥哥本来可以做点什么来提升她的语言能力，但他并没有。
Why haven't you put her in those classes?
为什么你不让她参加那些课程？
She doesn't want to do it.
她不想去。
Yeah, but she's nine. She doesn't want to do anything. I don't think she wants to wash her butt. Like--
是啊，但她才9岁。她什么都不想做。我觉得她连屁股都不想洗。就像……
But I don't want to-- I also don't-- I'm super lazy. So if it's like the reality is driving to the [INAUDIBLE] at 8:30 on a Sunday, that's not going to happen. I can barely get her to go to karate, something she is interested in.
但我不想……我也不……我超级懒。所以如果现实是周日上午8点半开车去[听不清]的话，那是不可能发生的。我连带她去学空手道都费劲，那还是她感兴趣的东西。
As for my brother, he's not likely to sign up for a class himself, despite having the urge, just like I do.
至于我哥哥，尽管他和我一样有冲动，但他自己也不太可能报名参加课程。
Do I think about practicing? Yeah, all the time. But I just don't.
我有没有想过练习？有，一直都在想。但我就是不去。
(LAUGHING) Why not?
（笑）为什么不呢？
I don't because our parents are merciless when you try to learn something new, and I'm not interested in giving them more fodder for jokes.
我不去是因为我们的父母在你尝试学习新东西时是毫不留情的，我没兴趣给他们提供更多的笑料。
What do you mean that they're merciless about--
你说的毫不留情是什么意思……
Have you ever tried to speak a language that they know in front of them?
你在他们面前尝试过说他们懂的语言吗？
Yeah.
试过。
Yeah, how'd that go?
是啊，感觉怎么样？
Um--
呃……
Yeah, exactly.
是啊，正是如此。
I'd say it's a spicy experience.
我会说那是一种“火辣”的体验。
That doesn't mean anything to me, but OK.
这对我不意味着什么，但好吧。
Do you think that we turned out the way he wanted, that he'd-- like when he--
你觉得我们长成他想要的样子了吗，他……当他……
No. No, I don't think we did, at all.
没有。没有，我不认为我们长成了他想要的样子，一点也没有。
If we didn't turn out the way our dad wanted us to, well, my dad bears a lot of responsibility for that. For one thing, instead of forcing us to learn Hindi, he made us learn French.
如果我们没能长成父亲想要的样子，好吧，我父亲对此要承担很大责任。首先，他没有强迫我们学习印地语，而是让我们学习法语。
Why instead of making me take Hindi classes at the temple, did you decide, oh, I know, I'm going to put them in French immersion for some reason?
为什么比起让我去寺庙上印地语课，你决定，哦，我知道了，由于某种原因我要送他们去法语沉浸式学校？
Because Canada is a bilingual country. And I was hoping that the Hindi would come automatically because at home and other Indians.
因为加拿大是一个双语国家。我本希望印地语能自动学会，因为在家和其他印度人在一起嘛。
My dad is loquacious and wry and thinks he's the smartest person in the room. He's also stubborn as hell, and so am I, which means we're often trying to murder each other. After I first got together with the man who would become my husband, the way older white guy, my dad didn't talk to me for a year. When I first asked him how he feels about me taking these classes, he's his typical self-- dismissive and glib.
我父亲健谈且带有嘲讽，认为自己是屋里最聪明的人。他也很固执，我也是，这意味着我们经常试图“谋杀”对方。在我开始和后来成为我丈夫的那个男人——那个年纪大的白人——在一起后，我父亲有一年没跟我说话。当我第一次问他对我参加这些课程有什么感觉时，他依然是他那种典型的风格——轻蔑且油嘴滑舌。
What did you think when I started taking the Hindi classes?
当我开始上印地语课时，你是怎么想的？
I was amused. Since you do whatever you want to do, I thought maybe, OK, good.
我感到很有趣。既然你总是随心所欲，我想也许，好的，不错。
What does that mean, I do whatever I want to do?
“随心所欲”是什么意思？
Because you are a very independent-minded person. You do not take any instruction or anything. So I was glad that at least you are doing something for your betterment. Because, like I said, having knowledge of another language can never hurt you.
因为你是一个非常有独立思想的人。你不接受任何人的指示或建议。所以我很高兴你至少在为自己的进步做点什么。因为，就像我说的，掌握另一种语言永远不会伤害你。
Don't be fooled by his detached attitude about whether I speak Hindi. He has other feelings as well, depending on the day. He used to get upset about it. When I was younger, sometimes he would speak to me in Kashmiri and quickly get frustrated that I could barely understand it and couldn't respond. He gave that up after I moved out.
别被他对我是否说印地语那副漠不关心的态度给骗了。他还有其他感受，视当天的情况而定。他以前会因此感到不安。我小时候，有时他会用克什米尔语和我说话，很快就会因为我听不太懂也没法回应而感到沮丧。我搬出去住之后，他就放弃了。
But ever since I started my Hindi classes, he's trying again. Now when I call my mother, he'll barge into our calls and demand that she speak to me in Hindi and Kashmiri. I had to ask him the same question over and over again before he finally admits that, yes, he's absolutely thrilled at the idea of me learning Hindi.
但自从我开始上印地语课后，他又开始尝试了。现在每当我给母亲打电话，他就会闯入我们的通话，要求她用印地语和克什米尔语跟我说话。我不得不一遍又一遍地问他同样的问题，他最终才承认，是的，他对我也许会学习印地语感到非常激动。
And hopefully, one day, you will converse with somebody in Hindi. And you should go to India. I'll go with you, but let you lead so that you can speak with taxi drivers or auto rickshaw drivers or shopkeepers, and try to haggle with them in Hindi. I bet you it'll be hilarious. It'll be wonderful.
希望有一天，你能用印地语和别人交流。你应该去印度。我会陪你一起，但让你带路，这样你就可以用印地语和出租车司机、自动三轮车司机或店主交谈，尝试用印地语跟他们讨价还价。我敢打赌这会很有趣。那将是美妙的。
Were you surprised that I started taking lessons?
你对我开始上课感到惊讶吗？
Yeah, I was. Because you were-- both you kids were extremely whitewashed. Maybe I had something to do with it. I didn't purposely do that.
是的，我是。因为你……你们两个孩子都被极度“漂白”了。也许这和我也有关系。我不是故意的。
Exactly what my dad had to do with that goes all the way back to his arrival in Canada. This is who my dad was when me and my brother were kids-- 125 pounds, 5 foot 4, ambitious, and working hard as a pharmaceutical representative. It was all so we would eventually have all you could ever want-- house, two cars, a yard, university educations. We were middle class in Canada, all with traditional Hindu names. It was the Indian dream.
我父亲到底在这件事上做了什么，要追溯到他刚到加拿大时。这就是我父亲和我哥哥小时候的样子——125磅，5英尺4英寸，雄心勃勃，作为一名药企代表努力工作。这一切都是为了让我们最终拥有你想要的一切——房子、两辆车、院子、大学教育。我们在加拿大是中产阶级，都有传统的印度名字。这就是印度梦。
We didn't have much family near us in Calgary. I didn't go to school with any other brown kids until I was well into high school. My brother and cousin spoke to each other and me in English. My father had this idea that we'd pick up Hindi at home, but that's ridiculous. My parents spoke Kashmiri and English. Hindi was reserved for Bollywood movies and when my mom needed to speak to her jeweler. What form of osmosis is my dad even talking about?
我们在卡尔加里附近没多少亲戚。直到上了高中，我才和其他棕色皮肤的孩子一起上学。我哥哥和表亲之间以及和我交流都用英语。我父亲有个想法，认为我们会在家里耳濡目染学会印地语，但这简直荒谬。我父母说克什米尔语和英语。印地语是留给宝莱坞电影的，或者是母亲需要跟她的珠宝商交流时用的。我父亲说的到底是什么形式的渗透？
I thought that this language, mother tongue specifically, would come a little later on. And I should concentrate on you being totally assimilated with the Canadian culture, if you will, whatever that culture is. But somehow I should have created some sort of infrastructure where you would be-- you would learn and be at least proficient in one of the languages-- Indian languages, that is.
我以为这种语言，特别是母语，会稍微晚一点掌握。我应该专注于让你们完全融入加拿大文化，如果你愿意这么说的话，无论那是什么文化。但不知何故，我本应该建立某种基础设施，让你们能够……至少精通其中一种语言——我是说印度语言。
Well, why didn't you make me take lessons for either Hindi or Kashmiri?
那么，你为什么没让我上印地语或克什米尔语的课呢？
I don't know. I don't know why. I ought to have done it.
我不知道。我不知道为什么。我本该做的。
I don't think my dad is equipped to directly talk about how hard it was to leave India. My mom can talk about her sadness easily, as if all those feelings are still right at the surface of her skin, waiting to bleed out of her and drown me.
我不认为我父亲有能力直接谈论离开印度有多难。我母亲可以轻易谈论她的悲伤，仿佛所有那些感受依然浮现在她的皮肤表面，等着从她身上流出来，将我淹没。
I had to say goodbye to my dad and my mother. That was very hard. That was really, really hard.
我不得不跟我的父亲和母亲告别。那真的很艰难。那真的非常非常艰难。
My dad was the family's sole breadwinner, and in her early days in Canada, my mother was alone a lot with my brother, just a toddler. She noticed he was losing his Kashmiri three or four months after they arrived.
我父亲是家里的唯一经济支柱，刚到加拿大的那段时间，我母亲经常独自带着我哥哥，当时他只是个蹒跚学步的孩子。他们到达三四个月后，她注意到他正在失去他的克什米尔语。
And I would talk to him in Kashmiri, and he would answer me in English. And I said, OK, this is it. He's not going to say anything back now. And I would push him and say it in Kashmiri, and he would say it in English. He would not say in Kashmiri.
我会用克什米尔语跟他说话，而他会用英语回答我。我说，好吧，就是这样。他现在什么都不会回了。我会强迫他，用克什米尔语说，但他会用英语说。他不会说克什米尔语。
So then why didn't you push him to keep it up?
那么你为什么不强迫他坚持下去呢？
Well, how can you make him do-- push-- how can you make him to speak?
好吧，你怎么能让他做……强迫……你怎么能让他开口？
When bhai got a little older, my mother and father considered signing him up for Hindi classes. And it turns out their reason for not doing so is the exact same practical, yet lazy one my big brother gives about Raisin.
当Bhai大一点时，我母亲和父亲考虑过给他报名印地语课程。事实证明，他们没这么做的理由和当初我哥哥提到葡萄干时那个既实际又懒惰的理由一模一样。
Papa said Sunday morning, I don't want to get up at 10 o'clock and take him to Hindi school. That was only because Hindi schools, that's what the timing. Sunday's the only day when I had my day off. And I was not that confident driving that time on the Deerfoot in wintertime. So that's all. Fell apart.
爸爸说周日上午，我不想在10点起床带他去印地语学校。那是因为印地语学校的课程安排就是那个时间。周日是我唯一休息的一天。而且在那时候的冬天，我没自信在Deerfoot路上开车。所以就这样。事情泡汤了。
My mother says that years later, they actually put me in Hindi classes. I was maybe five then. She says that I'd wander out of class, which was held in the basement of our [INAUDIBLE], and would trot up the stairs to find her. I don't remember this at all. They stopped trying to force it. At the time, I'm sure I was thrilled that they left it alone.
我母亲说多年以后，他们真的让我去上了印地语课。我那时大概五岁。她说我会从教室里走出来（教室设在我们[听不清]的地下室），然后踏着步子走上楼梯去找她。我对此完全没印象。他们停止了强迫尝试。在那时，我肯定很高兴他们放过了我。
I pushed against brownness in every way I could. I recoiled when my white friends would call and overhear my parents speaking Kashmiri in the background. I didn't want to invite them over because they could smell sandalwood in the curtains. I resented my unpronounceable first name and passively let people call me Sasha or Sara or Scratchy or Sushi or whatever examples of genteel racism were permeating my life.
我以各种可能的方式抗拒我的棕色人种特征。当我的白人朋友打电话来，听到背景里我父母用克什米尔语交谈时，我会退缩。我不想邀请他们过来，因为他们会闻到窗帘上的檀香。我痛恨我那无法发音的名字，被动地让人们叫我萨莎、萨拉、斯克拉奇、寿司，或者任何在我生活中渗透的温和种族主义的例子。
Are you disappointed that I can't speak Kashmiri and I can't speak Hindi?
你对我不会说克什米尔语和印地语感到失望吗？
I wouldn't say disappointed. But I feel sad that it would have been nice. Because sometimes if I want to tell you something, and I have to change the language, it loses its-- what I want to tell you. So that time, I'm really frustrated. I say I wish she could understand what I'm trying to tell her.
我不会说失望。但我感到难过，因为那本该是件好事。因为有时如果我想告诉你什么，而我必须转换语言，它就会失去……我想要告诉你的那种味道。所以那一刻，我真的很沮丧。我说我希望她能听懂我想告诉她什么。
Sometimes I could see my mom struggling to find the right word to convey the right feeling. Has she always felt a gap between what she wanted to tell me and what I was able to grasp? When I moved away for university, I worried my mom would be lonely. I resented that I worried about her. But I wondered who my mom would talk to when I left home. I never considered that maybe the language we were speaking left her feeling lonely, before I even moved away.
有时我能看到我母亲在努力寻找合适的词汇来表达正确的感受。她是否一直觉得想告诉我的内容和我也能领会的内容之间有鸿沟？我离开家去上大学时，我担心我母亲会孤独。我对自己担心她感到不满。但我好奇当我离家后，谁会跟我的母亲交谈。我从未考虑过，也许我们所说的语言在我离开家之前就让她感到孤独了。
Did you want me and bhai to assimilate in Canada?
你希望我和Bhai在加拿大融入吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Did we assimilate too much?
我们融入得太过分了吗？
Well, I will say yes and no to that. It would have been nice if a little bit stayed towards your heritage, towards your culture. But I guess it was supposed to happen, and there's nothing I can do about it.
好吧，我既会说是的也会说不是。如果能有一点点保留向着你的遗产，向着你的文化，那该多好。但我猜这注定会发生，对此我无能为力。
This idea from both of my parents makes me nuts. Of course there's something she could have done about it. I know that my parents made the best choices they had at the time. Now, though, I feel like I missed out on something that I desperately want.
父母双方的这个想法让我发疯。当然，她本可以做些什么的。我知道我父母在当时做出了他们所能做的最好选择。但现在，我却觉得自己错过了一些我极其渴望的东西。
I wish I could have spoken to your mom when she was alive.
我希望我能在你母亲在世时和她交流。
Yeah, well, I wish that you--
是啊，好吧，我希望你……
I mean, did that-- did she say anything to you about that, that she couldn't speak to her grandchildren?
我是说，有没有……她有没有对你说过那件事，说她无法和她的孙辈交流？
Yeah, she used to cry and cry and cry. She says, I cannot speak to them, and they don't understand me. And I wish I could talk to them. So it was hard. It was a shame that you guys couldn't talk to her. She would have been overwhelmed if you would say just a few words. Now it is all gone, so it doesn't matter now. Anything else?
有，她过去常哭啊哭啊哭。她说，我无法和他们说话，他们听不懂我。我真希望我能和他们谈谈。所以这很艰难。真遗憾你们无法和她交流。如果你能说上几句，她一定会感动万分。现在一切都过去了，所以现在也无所谓了。还有别的吗？
Of course there's something else. There's always something else.
当然还有别的。永远还有别的。
What are we making first?
我们先做什么？
You said you wanted to see how we cook green beans, right?
你说你想看看我们怎么做青豆，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
Cooking is the only place where I don't know the English equivalency of most words, evidenced by how many times I go to the grocery store and ask for amruth or elaichi, and struggle to name it in English. In the kitchen, my pronunciation is flawless. And for once, I don't feel like a fraud when I speak in Hindi or Kashmiri.
烹饪是我唯一不知道大多数词汇英语对应词的地方，有多少次我去杂货店询问amruth（芒果）或elaichi（小豆蔻），却难以用英语叫出名字，这证明了一切。在厨房里，我的发音完美无缺。有生以来第一次，当我说印地语或克什米尔语时，我不觉得自己在假装。
When I was a kid, I wouldn't even let my mom pack me Indian food for lunch. No one wants to be different in a grade school cafeteria. Then I moved away for university, and I realized all I wanted was my mom's cooking. I wanted her to braid my hair and rub my back and wax my mustache off for me, all these blips of intimacy with her I once had. I've been learning how to make her food ever since.
小时候，我甚至不让我妈给我带印度食物当午餐。没人想在小学食堂里显得格格不入。后来我搬走去上大学，我意识到我想要的就是我妈妈做的菜。我想要她帮我编头发，帮我揉背，帮我脱掉嘴上的汗毛，所有这些我曾经拥有的亲密点滴。从那以后，我一直在学习如何做她的菜。
My beans always turn out weird.
我的豆子总是做得很奇怪。
Why?
为什么？
I don't know. They get too salty.
我不知道。它们太咸了。
Maybe you are putting too much salt. Simple.
也许是你放了太多盐。就这么简单。
Yeah, Mom, I know. God. How is that helpful?
是的，妈，我知道。天哪。这有什么帮助吗？
My Hindi, after a few months of lessons, is finally good enough that I can have slivers of conversations with my parents. Recently, they visited me in New York. And on a walk with my husband barely two feet ahead of us, my mother told me in Hindi, your husband has no butt.
经过几个月的课程，我的印地语终于进步到可以和父母进行一些零星的对话了。最近，他们到纽约来看我。在和我丈夫保持不到两英尺距离的一次散步中，我母亲用印地语对我说：“你丈夫没有屁股。”
One day, my parents will die. And when that happens, we'll all forget the insults and the sounds and the way my mom rolls her Rs. I can't even imagine how lonely I'll be without her sounds. Maybe it'll hurt less if I learn how to make these sounds on my own. For now, I'm still stumbling over how to say "I love you" to my mother in her mother tongue.
终有一天，我的父母会离世。当那天到来时，我们都会忘记那些侮辱、声音以及我母亲卷舌音的方式。我甚至无法想象没有她的声音我会多么孤独。也许如果我自己学会了如何发出这些声音，痛苦会少一点。目前，我还在如何用母语向我的母亲说“我爱你”这件事上磕磕绊绊。
[SPEAKING KASHMIRI]
[克什米尔语]
Thank you.
谢谢。
My mom now tells me constantly how proud she is that I'm trying to learn Hindi. More than anything, that's what keeps me going to class.
我妈现在经常告诉我，她为我试图学习印地语感到多么骄傲。最重要的是，这正是让我坚持上课的动力。
Scaachi Koul, she writes about culture for BuzzFeed News, and she's also the author of a collection of essays, One Day We'll All Be Dead and None of This Will Matter.
斯卡奇·考尔，她为BuzzFeed新闻报道文化，她也是散文集《终有一天我们都会死，而这一切都无关紧要》（One Day We'll All Be Dead and None of This Will Matter）的作者。
[MUSIC - "DON'T LET ME BE MISUNDERSTOOD" BY NINA SIMONE]
[音乐 - 尼娜·西蒙的《别让我被误解》]
Coming up, they didn't mean it. They really didn't mean it. They really, really didn't mean it. Right? That's what they say. Mother and daughter, and the song they chose to sing at a very significant family event. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，他们不是那个意思。他们真的不是那个意思。他们真的、真的不是那个意思。对吧？他们就是这么说的。母亲和女儿，以及她们选择在一个非常重要的家庭活动上演唱的歌。稍后继续从芝加哥公共广播电台为您带来的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on the program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Too Close to Home." For the holidays, stories of family get-togethers where somebody shows up with something they think the entire family has to deal with, or at least, discuss. And they're ready to force the issue. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, You Probably Think This Song is About You.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们当然会选择一个主题，为您带来不同种类的故事。今天的主题是“太亲近家了”（Too Close to Home）。节日期间，关于家庭聚会的故事，有人带着他们认为整个家庭必须面对，或者至少必须讨论的事情出现。他们准备强行提出这个问题。我们进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，你大概觉得这首歌是关于你的。
So in this act, two family members show up with a message. The message is contained in a song, which makes sense because the family includes a bunch of musicians. The dad in this family is Loudon Wainwright III, the songwriter who started putting out albums in the 1970s. He is father to singer-songwriters Rufus Wainwright and Martha Wainwright, and with a different mom, Lucy Wainwright Roche. Lucy's mom is Suzzy Roche, who got some notoriety in the band The Roches. Lucy and Suzzy came into the studio to tell the story of this song.
在这一幕中，两位家庭成员带着信息出现。信息包含在一首歌中，这很有道理，因为这个家庭包括了一群音乐家。这个家庭的父亲是劳顿·温赖特三世（Loudon Wainwright III），一位从1970年代开始发行专辑的唱作人。他是创作歌手鲁弗斯·温赖特（Rufus Wainwright）和玛莎·温赖特（Martha Wainwright）的父亲，以及与另一位母亲所生的露西·温赖特·罗什（Lucy Wainwright Roche）的父亲。露西的母亲是苏茜·罗什（Suzzy Roche），她在乐队The Roches中颇有名气。露西和苏茜来到演播室讲述这首歌背后的故事。
We sang this one, actually, at one of my dad's weddings.
我们实际上是在我父亲的一场婚礼上唱的这首歌。
To be precise, her dad, Loudon, had gotten married for the second time. And this was a party to celebrate it, maybe 50 people. Lucy went with her mom, Suzzy, who'd never been married to Loudon, but they were together for years.
准确地说，她的父亲劳顿当时是第二次结婚。这是一场庆祝婚礼的派对，大概有50人参加。露西和她母亲苏茜一起去了，苏茜从未与劳顿结婚，但他们在一起生活了很多年。
And he asked us if we wanted to sing something, and we said, sure. And then he was like, OK, well, pick whatever you feel like singing and surprise us. And we'd been learning this song that was a cover song that we just really liked. And sometimes when you're learning a new song, you kind of have a little crush on the song, so you just want to sing it all the time. And so we were like, let's just do that new one that we've been learning. And we just didn't really think it through.
他问我们想不想唱点什么，我们说，当然。然后他说，好吧，选你们想唱的歌给我们一个惊喜。我们当时正在学这首歌，这是一首翻唱曲，我们真的很喜欢。有时当你学习一首新歌时，你会对这首歌有点“暗恋”，所以你只想一直唱它。所以我们就想，不如就唱那首我们一直在学的新歌吧。我们确实没考虑周全。
Yeah, I would say that that's an understatement. I don't know what we were thinking. I mean, it was one of those kind of situations where you're standing in front of a roomful of people, and they all have their champagne glasses. And they're looking at you, smiling. And you start to sing the song. And so just imagine that you're at a wedding, and--
是啊，我想说这还是轻描淡写的。我不知道我们在想什么。我是说，那是那种站在满屋子人面前，他们手里都拿着香槟酒杯，看着你微笑的情况之一。你开始唱歌。所以想象一下你在婚礼上，并且……
Yeah, you're--
是啊，你是……
--these people are going to sing.
……这些人要唱歌了。
You got your champagne, and then this happens.
你手里拿着香槟，然后，这事儿发生了。
All right. Let's hear the song.
好的，让我们听听这首歌。
[MUSIC - "DESPERADO" BY LUCY WAINWRIGHT ROCHE AND SUZZY ROCHE]
[音乐 - 露西·温赖特·罗什和苏茜·罗什翻唱的《亡命之徒》（Desperado）]
(SINGING) Desperado, why don't you come to your senses? You've been out riding fences for so long now. Well, you're a hard one. I know that you've got your reasons. These things that are pleasing you can hurt you somehow.
（演唱）亡命之徒，你为什么不恢复理智？你已经在篱笆外骑行了太久。好吧，你是个硬骨头。我知道你有你的理由。这些让你愉悦的事情也可能以某种方式伤害你。
OK, so at this point, what are they thinking?
好的，那么此时此刻，她们在想什么？
I feel like as soon as you sing, "Desperado," people think, oh-- oh.
我觉得一旦你唱出“亡命之徒”，人们就会想，哦……哦。
They're talking about Loudon.
她们在说劳顿。
I bet more than anything, they felt like, what is happening right now?
我敢打赌，她们感觉到的远不止这些，她们在想，“现在发生了什么？”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Like, is this OK?
就像，这合适吗？
Is this a message?
这是一个信号吗？
It's a slightly hostile thing to sing at your father's wedding, or your ex's wedding.
在父亲的婚礼上，或者前任的婚礼上唱这首歌，是一件略带敌意的事情。
But we were thinking, (SINGING) G, G7, C, C Minor. And basically concentrating on playing it, because I didn't know it that well.
但我们当时想的是，（演唱）G，G7，C，C小调。基本上专注于弹奏它，因为我还没那么熟练。
OK, keep going.
好的，继续。
(SINGING) Don't you draw the Queen of Diamonds. She'll beat you if she's able. You know the Queen of Hearts is always your best bet. Now it seems to me some fine things have been laid upon your table. But you only want the ones that you can't get.
（演唱）别去抽那张方块Q。如果她能赢你，她会赢你的。你知道红桃Q永远是你的最佳赌注。现在看来，一些美好的事物已经被摆在你的桌上。但你只想要那些你得不到的东西。
What do you think people thought at that point?
你觉得人们在那一点上是怎么想的？
I think that is the most cringey line in the song.
我认为那是这首歌里最让人尴尬的一句词。
In this context.
在这种语境下。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah. "It seems to me some fine things have been laid upon your table, and you only want the ones that you can't get." I mean, that--
是啊。“看来一些美好的东西已经被摆在你的桌上，但你只想要那些你得不到的。”我是说，这……
That seems rude. You don't often hear a wedding toast that says like, and what I love about him is, lucky you. He never wants the things he can get. That's not--
这看起来很不礼貌。你很少听到婚礼祝酒词说，“他最可爱的地方就是，幸运的你。他从来都不想要他能得到的东西。”那不是……
No, I haven't heard that at a wedding. Weird.
不，我没在婚礼上听到过。真怪。
No. I think that's the low point of what we've done here.
不。我认为这是我们所做过的事情中的最低点。
Let's go into the next verse. "Oh, you ain't getting no younger."
让我们进入下一段。“噢，你可没变年轻。”
Right. I would say this is the second to worst line of the song.
没错。我会说这是这首歌里第二糟糕的歌词。
(SINGING) Desperado, oh, you ain't getting no younger. Your pain and your hunger are driving you home. And freedom, oh, that's just some people talking. Your prison is walking through this world all alone.
（演唱）亡命之徒，噢，你可没变年轻。你的痛苦和饥饿正在驱使你回家。而自由，噢，那只是人们口中的谈资。你的牢笼就是独自走过这个世界。
So how do you think people might have heard that?
那么你觉得人们是怎么听到的？
Oh, it's so sad. That is so sad.
噢，太悲哀了。那真是太悲哀了。
It is so sad.
真的很悲哀。
Now the line, "You ain't getting no younger," how old was your dad?
现在那句“你可没变年轻”，你父亲当时多大了？
Old.
老了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He was not getting any younger.
他确实没变年轻。
So you're singing this, and you're looking around at the faces. What are you seeing?
所以你在唱这个，而且你在环顾人们的脸。你看到了什么？
It didn't feel like it was the most well-received thing we'd ever done.
感觉那不是我们做过最受欢迎的事情。
Yeah.
是啊。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, I mean, there was a kind of a feeling of being looked at without a lot of expression, which is sometimes not a great sign. [LAUGHS]
是啊，我是说，那种感觉就是被盯着看却没有太多的表情，这有时可不是什么好迹象。[笑]
I think they were probably thinking a thought that I think a lot when something happens that is uncomfortable. And when something like that is happening, like, just make the right kind of face right now.
我想他们当时可能在想一种我在事情变得尴尬时常想到的念头。当那种事情发生时，就像是，“现在赶紧摆出合适的表情来”。
[LAUGHS] And maybe this will be over soon.
[笑] 而且也许这事儿快点结束吧。
Yes. Like, just make sure your face is right.
是的。就像，确保你的表情是对的。
I mean, the truth of it is that nobody has ever mentioned it again to us.
我是说，事实是从来没人再向我们提起这件事。
To this day.
直到今天。
Yeah.
是啊。
What did he say afterwards?
事后他说什么了吗？
Nothing.
什么也没说。
Did he say thank you?
他说谢谢了吗？
No. Not really, no.
没有。并没有，没有。
The horrible thing about this is that people must have felt like we were doing something passive aggressive, or aggressive maybe.
这件事最糟糕的地方在于，人们肯定觉得我们是在做某种被动攻击，或者也许是主动攻击。
Right. And the sad thing is we were completely oblivious. And I know that that probably sounds like maybe it's not true, and unconsciously, we had some sort of thing we were doing. Perhaps, but it didn't feel like that at all.
没错。而可悲的是，我们完全没意识到。我知道这听起来可能不像真的，而且潜意识里我们可能在做某种事情。也许吧，但当时完全没这种感觉。
But I think then after that, a couple years later when we first performed this song in a show, I might have said to the audience for the first time, oh, actually, we sang this once at my dad's wedding. And then the absurdity of that really hit us.
但我想在那之后，几年后当我们第一次在演出中表演这首歌时，我可能第一次对观众说了，“哦，其实我们曾在我父亲的婚礼上唱过这首歌。”然后那种荒谬感真正击中了我们。
Right, and also the song kind of turns into a comedy, instead of the beautiful song that it is.
没错，而且这首歌变成了一种喜剧，而不是它原本优美的样子。
Let's hear a recording from one of those concerts.
让我们听听那场音乐会上的录音。
(SINGING) Desperado--
（演唱）亡命之徒……
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--why don't you come to your senses?
……你为什么不恢复理智？
It's weird that you can get a song like this to play as comedy.
能把这样一首歌变成喜剧真是不可思议。
I mean, people get hysterical when they hear it in that context, which makes it obvious that there was something strange about it.
我是说，当人们在这种语境下听到它时，他们会歇斯底里，这显然说明它有些奇怪的地方。
(SINGING) Now it seems to me some fine things have been laid upon your table. But you only want the ones that you can't get.
（演唱）现在看来一些美好的事物已经被摆在你的桌上。但你只想要那些你得不到的东西。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Desperado, no, you ain't getting no younger.
亡命之徒，你可没变年轻。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, here's the other thing about it. I don't know if I should say this, but I mean, on the one hand, it's a terrible thing to sing at a wedding and at that wedding. But on the other hand, it's kind of the perfect thing to sing at that wedding.
好吧，关于这件事还有一点。我不知道我该不该说，但我意思的一方面，在婚礼上唱那首歌确实很糟糕。但另一方面，在那个婚礼上唱这首歌又堪称完美。
I know.
我知道。
How do you mean it's the perfect thing to sing?
你怎么说它是完美的演唱曲目？
Well, because you're basically-- the lyrics, if you really study them, are basically saying you've got to let somebody love you.
好吧，因为你基本上……如果你仔细研究歌词，它基本上是在说，你必须让某人来爱你。
So you're saying, unconsciously maybe, it was the perfect pick for the wedding.
所以你是说，也许潜意识里，它是婚礼的完美选择。
Right, I'm starting to change my mind on this whole thing and say that, yes, of course we meant to sing this song.
没错，我开始改变对整件事的看法，并说，是的，当然我们就是故意要唱这首歌的。
I'm not.
我可不这么想。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
When I see what it's actually saying, what it says to me, if there is a subconscious message that we were aiming at Loudon-- or I'll speak for myself, me-- is just, I see you. I see what you've been through, and I see your pain. And we're happy for you that you've found somebody to be with.
当我看到它实际上在表达什么，如果有什么潜意识的信息是我们针对劳顿的——或者我只代表我自己——那只是，我看见你了。我看见了你所经历的一切，我看见了你的痛苦。而且我们为你找到了一个人来陪伴你感到高兴。
Suzzy and Lucy Roche. Their version of "Desperado" is on their album Mud and Apples. Lucy's most recent album is Little Beast. I did, by the way, check with Loudon, Suzzy's ex and Lucy's dad, to see what he thought about "Desperado" as their choice of song at the party, since they really had no idea at all. And Loudon told me he definitely remembered it.
苏茜和露西·罗什。她们翻唱的《亡命之徒》收录在她们的专辑《泥与苹果》（Mud and Apples）中。露西最近的专辑是《小野兽》（Little Beast）。顺便说一下，我确实向劳顿（苏茜的前任和露西的父亲）核实了一下，看看他怎么看待“亡命之徒”作为她们在派对上选择的曲目，因为她们当时真的毫无察觉。劳顿告诉我，他确实记得这件事。
Oh, yes. Yes. I remember thinking it was hilariously funny and ironic. And I thought it was a kind of really ironic, cool choice of a song to do.
噢，是的。是的。我记得当时觉得它极其搞笑且讽刺。我本认为选择这样一首歌来唱是一个非常讽刺、酷炫的选择。
[MUSIC - "WHAT ARE FAMILIES FOR?" BY LOUDON WAINWRIGHT III]
[音乐 - 劳顿·温赖特三世的《家庭是为了什么？》]
Music from Loudon Wainwright III, which brings us to Act Three of our show. Act Three, Pigeons on a Plane. So we have one more family member on a mission for you today, and this mission was made possible by a government official, a government official in Mexico, namely the Secretary of Migration in the Mexican state of Michoacán. And a little while back, this official, he started to hear that lots of elderly people in Mexico were dying without being able to see their kids. Because their kids were living in the United States and were undocumented. And the kids didn't have the papers to cross in and out of Mexico.
来自劳顿·温赖特三世的音乐，这把我们带到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，飞机上的鸽子。今天我们要为您介绍另一位带着使命的家庭成员，这项使命是由一位政府官员实现的，墨西哥米却肯州的一位移民秘书。不久前，这位官员听说墨西哥有许多老人死前未能见到他们的孩子。因为他们的孩子生活在美国，而且是无证件的。孩子们没有往返墨西哥的证件。
The migration secretary wanted to help, and he set up a program to help these elderly Mexicans with families in the US get tourist visas. They have special days at the US embassy for them to apply, buses to take them to the embassy. And then they organized these trips, these trips were they fly them to the United States en masse. These elderly people get regular tourist visas with the same rules as any other tourist visas, but good for 10 years so that they can come and go and see their kids and grandkids in the US. You have to be 60 years old qualify for the program.
这位移民秘书想提供帮助，他建立了一个项目，帮助这些在美国有亲人的墨西哥老人获得旅游签证。他们有专门的日子在美国大使馆申请，有大巴车送他们去使馆。然后他们组织了这些旅行，将他们成群结队地飞往美国。这些老人获得的是常规旅游签证，与其他任何旅游签证规则相同，但有效期为10年，以便他们能来来往往探望在美国的孩子和孙辈。申请该项目需年满60岁。
And since 2017, over 9,000 people have come to the States this way. Not one of them, we're told, has ever overstayed a visa. Over a dozen other Mexican states have created their own versions of the program. In Michoacán, the elderly travelers are known as palomas mensajeras, the messenger pigeons. Reporter Kevin Sieff tagged along on one of their trips. He started in Mexico and flew to the US with them.
自2017年以来，已有超过9000人通过这种方式来到美国。据我们所知，没有一个人滞留过期。十多个其他墨西哥州也创建了他们自己的版本。在米却肯州，这些老年旅行者被称为“信鸽”（palomas mensajeras）。记者凯文·西夫（Kevin Sieff）跟随了其中一次旅行。他从墨西哥出发，与他们一起飞往美国。
I'm standing with a group of 70 elderly palomas mensajeras. They're all wearing matching T-shirts and have lanyards around their necks with these big clear pouches, holding their airport tickets and passports. It looks like a giant group of really old schoolchildren. To make sure no one's wandered off, the chaperones take a roll call.
我正和70位老年“信鸽”待在一起。他们都穿着统一的T恤，脖子上挂着挂绳，绳子上系着巨大的透明袋子，里面装着机票和护照。这看起来就像一大群真的老了的学生。为了确保没人走失，领队进行了点名。
[READING NAMES]
[朗读名单]
We're at a small airport in central Mexico. The people in this group have some very specific things in common. None of them has ever flown on an airplane before, and they're all headed to Chicago to see their kids for the first time in more than a decade.
我们是在墨西哥中部的一个小机场。这个团体中的人有一些非常具体的共同点。他们中没有人坐过飞机，而且他们都要去芝加哥，去见他们十年多没见的孩子。
The biggest migration boom from Mexico happened in the 1990s, nearly 5 million people by the end of the decade. The exodus was especially big in a city called Ciudad Hidalgo, where these parents are from. By 1998, roughly 10% of the city's population was living in Chicago. Today, the kids who cross the border as teenagers and 20 somethings are middle-aged undocumented immigrants with children of their own, US citizen children who've never met their grandparents.
来自墨西哥的最大移民潮发生在1990年代，到十年末有近500万人。这种大迁徙在伊达尔戈城（Ciudad Hidalgo）尤为严重，这些父母就来自那里。到1998年，该市大约10%的人口生活在芝加哥。今天，那些以青少年和20多岁身份跨越边境的孩子们，成了人到中年的无证移民，他们也有了自己的孩子，那些从未见过祖父母的美国公民孩子们。
Those are the grandparents I'm with now. They board the plane slowly, so slowly, as you'd expect on a flight where almost everyone is elderly, on canes and wheelchairs, and utterly unaccustomed to air travel.
那些就是我现在相伴的祖父母们。他们缓慢地登上飞机，如此缓慢，正如你对一架几乎全是老人的航班所预期的那样，拄着拐杖，坐着轮椅，完全不习惯航空旅行。
Sort of chaotic now as everyone's boarding, a lot of confusion about where people are sitting. This woman's asking, am I in the right seat? Is this the right seat? She's actually in the wrong seat.
登机时现在有点混乱，很多人不清楚自己坐在哪儿。这位女士在问，我是不是坐错座位了？这是正确的位子吗？她确实坐错了。
The parent I ended up talking to the most was a mom named Lupita Neri. At 67, she was one of the younger parents on the trip. She sat in the front of the plane in a window seat, wearing a yellow dress and heels and bright pink lipstick.
我交谈最多的家长是一位名叫卢皮塔·内里（Lupita Neri）的母亲。67岁的她是这次旅行中较年轻的家长之一。她坐在飞机前部的靠窗座位上，穿着黄色连衣裙和高跟鞋，涂着鲜亮的粉色口红。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
She's saying she expected the plane to move like a truck, but it didn't. Lupita's son, Daniel, and daughter, Marilu, have been in Chicago for almost 20 years.
她说她原以为飞机移动起来会像卡车，但并没有。卢皮塔的儿子丹尼尔和女儿玛丽露在芝加哥已经快20年了。
For you guys, you've only been able to talk over the phone. Is there anything you've been waiting to talk to them about in person?
对你们来说，你们只能通过电话交流。有什么事情是你一直在等候当面跟他们谈的吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Well, I'm going to, of course, get there. And then I'm going to greet my children and my grandchildren. But then there are some things that we're going to have to talk about once we're at home, about what they are going to do. Because I want my kids to come here to be with me. Because I'm all alone here.
好吧，我当然要去那边。然后我要去迎接我的孩子和孙子们。但还有一些事情是我们到了家里必须谈的，关于他们打算做什么。因为我希望我的孩子们能回来这里跟我在一起。因为我一个人在这儿。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
In fact, this was her mission for the trip. Like parents everywhere, she wants to convince her children to move back home. For months, she'd been preparing what to say, practicing her pitch in the mirror.
事实上，这就是她此次旅行的任务。像各地的父母一样，她想说服她的孩子们搬回家。几个月来，她一直在准备说什么，在镜子里练习她的说辞。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Yeah, I mean, I actually will, like, talk to myself. I'll say, OK, well, are you going to stay here forever? Or are you going to come back? Because I've said this before, but Chicago isn't your homeland. This is your homeland. And you've already had the opportunity to enjoy Chicago, to work there, but now it's time to come back. So please come back so that you can be with me.
是啊，我的意思是，我确实会，就像，自言自语。我会说，好吧，你打算永远待在那儿吗？或者你打算回来吗？因为我以前说过，但芝加哥不是你们的家乡。这是你们的家乡。而且你们已经有机会享受芝加哥了，在那里工作过，但现在是回来的时候了。所以请回来吧，这样你们就能和我在一起了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
This won't be news to her kids. She's brought it up before.
这对她的孩子们来说不是什么新闻。她以前提过。
How often do you bring it up over the phone?
你在电话里多久提一次这事儿？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
About three times a year. I don't do it too much because I might get hung up on.
大约一年三次。我不敢提太多，因为我可能会被挂断。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
It's very touchy to talk about that kind of stuff over the phone because my son, he'll get upset. And he says, well, Mom, if I'm earning money to help you, then if I come back there to be with you, how are we going to live? And I tell him, well, from your perspective, you're seeing it as something that's so impossible. But it's not.
在电话里谈这种事很敏感，因为我儿子，他会心烦。他说，好吧，妈，如果我在挣钱帮你，那么如果我回到那边陪你，我们要怎么生活？我告诉他，好吧，从你的角度看，你觉得这是不可能的。但并不是这样。
Save up some money over there so that you can come back here without needing to go back to the United States. And yes, maybe we'll live humbly, and we'll be eating beans and eggs. But you'll at least be here in your home. And my son says, well, I'll think about it, Mom. I'll think about it.
在那里存点钱，这样你就能回来，而不需要再回美国了。是的，也许我们会过得谦卑些，我们会吃豆子和鸡蛋。但你们至少会在你们的家里。而我儿子说，好吧，我会考虑的，妈。我会考虑的。
Like a lot of the parents I talked to, Lupita never expected Daniel and Marilu to be gone for so long, at most just a few years. Save some money, and then come back to Mexico. That was their original plan. Daniel even bought a calendar and penciled in the date when he would return.
像我交谈过的许多家长一样，卢皮塔从没想过丹尼尔和玛丽露会离开这么久，最多也就几年。存点钱，然后回墨西哥。那是他们最初的计划。丹尼尔甚至买了本日历，并在回家的日期上做了标记。
But they kept pushing back the deadline, telling her they needed to save more money. Then they had children and houses and dogs and friends. It got harder to leave. Lupita was losing her patience. She'd been living alone since her husband died four years ago of cancer. She wanted her kids with her.
但他们不断推迟期限，告诉她他们需要存更多的钱。然后他们有了孩子、房子、狗和朋友。离开变得更难了。卢皮塔失去了耐心。自丈夫四年前死于癌症后，她一直独自生活。她想要孩子们在她身边。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Both of them have told me, Mom, just give me time. Just give me time. And I say, but I've already given you a lot of time.
他们俩都告诉过我，妈，再给我点时间。再给我点时间。而我说，但我已经给过你们很多时间了。
Lupita had another son, Isaac, who moved to the US and died of pneumonia a few years ago. She never had the chance to say goodbye, even over the phone. It made her feel like that could be her, dying without them. She wanted the kids back now.
卢皮塔还有另一个儿子艾萨克，他搬到了美国，几年前死于肺炎。她甚至没机会在电话里跟他告别。这让她觉得那可能就是她，孤独地死去，孩子们却不在身边。她现在就想让孩子们回来。
Daniel was the first to leave Mexico, back in 1999. He got a job as a dishwasher and then kept working his way up to bartending at fancy restaurants. Marilu joined Daniel in Chicago soon after. She was a single mom with five kids who needed more money for her family. She took cleaning jobs in Chicago. Now she works three jobs, including back-to-back night shifts, cleaning at a restaurant and a health clinic.
丹尼尔是第一个离开墨西哥的，那是1999年。他找到了一份洗碗工的工作，然后一步步努力做到了高级餐厅的调酒师。玛丽露很快也去了芝加哥。她是一位带着五个孩子的单亲母亲，需要更多的钱养家。她在芝加哥做清洁工作。现在她打三份工，包括连续的夜班，在一家餐厅和一家诊所做保洁。
Lupita says when she's brought up coming home on the phone, she's been pretty gentle. She thinks in person, it'll all be different. She'll be more aggressive, and her kids will really have to hear her out. Her plan was to wait until she'd been in Chicago for about a week before springing this conversation on them.
卢皮塔说，当她在电话里提到回家时，她一直很温和。她觉得面对面会完全不同。她会更强硬，她的孩子们真的必须听她的。她的计划是等在芝加哥待了一周左右，再向他们抛出这个话题。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So you got to just wait till everything is calm. Because if I do it immediately, then it'll be like dumping a bucket of cold water on their heads, and that might scare them off. So I'm going to wait for a day when my son takes me out to go sightseeing. And that's when I'll talk to him. We'll maybe go out to have a coffee, maybe eat a hamburger. And then I'll start talking to him about it.
所以你得等一切平静下来。因为如果我立刻这么做，那就像当头浇一盆冷水，那可能会把他们吓跑。所以我打算等到我儿子带我出去观光的那一天。那时候我就会跟他谈。我们也许会去喝咖啡，也许吃个汉堡。然后我就开始跟他说这事。
And Lupita kept making what sounded like a half joke, half backup plan about her son Daniel.
卢皮塔一直在开那种听起来半开玩笑、半是备选计划关于她儿子丹尼尔的话。
I think sometimes it would be so great if they could actually deport him back to be with me.
我觉得有时如果他们能真的被驱逐回来陪我，那该多好。
I asked Lupita what her kids would think if they knew she was saying that.
我问卢皮塔如果她的孩子们知道她这么说会怎么想。
Well, I think they'll get mad. They'll say, what are you talking about, Mom? But yes, this is something that I've thought about, that it might be better if they're deported because then they'll be deported to be back with me.
好吧，我想他们会生气的。他们会说，妈，你在胡说什么？但确实，我思考过这个问题，也许被驱逐会更好，因为这样他们就会被驱逐回来跟我在一起了。
She says in the past, she's gotten so frustrated about her kids not being home that she thought about going to the US embassy to report them.
她说在过去，她因为孩子们不回家而感到太沮丧，以至于她想过去美国大使馆举报他们。
[LAUGHS] I don't think she will be capable to do that.
[笑] 我想她没能力那么做。
This is Lupita's son Daniel. I caught up with him in Chicago.
这是卢皮塔的儿子丹尼尔。我在芝加哥赶上了他。
But maybe. You never know. [LAUGHS] I don't even get mad if she does. I'll be like, OK.
但也说不准。你永远不知道。[笑] 老实说，如果她真的那么做，我甚至不会生气。我会觉得，好吧。
You wouldn't get mad if she did that?
如果她那么做你也不会生气？
No.
不会。
What?
什么？
She's my mother, so. She gave me life, so. [LAUGHS] I started laughing, to be honest, because make me feel like, oh, she loves me very much.
她是我的母亲，所以。她给了我生命，所以。[笑] 老实说，我开始笑，因为这让我觉得，哦，她非常爱我。
Just as Lupita landed in Chicago with the rest of the parents, Daniel and Marilu and more than 100 other families were waiting in the basement of a packed church. The chaperones had specifically told them not to come to the airport. It wasn't a good idea to have so many undocumented people in a place with so much law enforcement. The organizers tried to keep details about the reunion secret. There's the sinking worry that ICE could find out. Some families worried that the whole thing could be a ploy to deport them.
就在卢皮塔和其他家长一起抵达芝加哥时，丹尼尔、玛丽露和另外100多个家庭正等在一个拥挤的教堂地下室里。领队特别叮嘱他们不要来机场。有这么多无证移民出现在执法力度很大的地方可不是个好主意。组织者试图对重聚细节保密。有一种隐隐的担忧，ICE（移民及海关执法局）可能会发现。一些家庭担心这可能是一个驱逐他们的伎俩。
In the church basement, about 300 people, all families, squished together, long folding tables piled with flowers, homemade posters, and heart-shaped balloons. There are grown men walking around with teddy bears for their moms. Then an MC standing near the door started giving updates about the parents landing at the airport, getting on buses headed to the church. The mood got rowdier.
在教堂地下室，大约300人，全是家庭，挤在一起，长长的折叠桌上堆满了鲜花、自制的横幅和心形气球。成年男子拿着给母亲的泰迪熊走来走去。然后一位主持人站在门口开始通报家长们降落机场、坐上前往教堂的大巴的消息。气氛变得热烈起来。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Lupita's son Daniel and her daughter, Marilu, are sitting at a table near the center of the room. They crane their necks to watch for the bus. Marilu has been waiting in the church basement for hours. She left three children in Mexico when she came to Chicago, and she brought two younger kids with her. It gnaws at her not seeing her kids back in Mexico. And she worries about her mom dying alone.
卢皮塔的儿子丹尼尔和女儿玛丽露坐在房间中央附近的一张桌子旁。他们伸长脖子看着大巴。玛丽露已经在教堂地下室等了几个小时。她来芝加哥时把三个孩子留在了墨西哥，她带了两个小的过来。看不到留在墨西哥的孩子让她备受煎熬。她也担心妈妈孤独地死去。
I feel sad. She's by herself. I worry about her. Sometimes I'm thinking about, what about if something happened to her? What'll we do? I don't want to let her die without me.
我感到难过。她一个人。我为她担心。有时我在想，如果她出了什么事怎么办？我们该怎么办？我不想让她死的时候我不在身边。
[MARIACHI MUSIC]
[玛利亚奇音乐]
Suddenly, this famous mariachi song came on. And Marilu started singing along, loudly.
突然，这首著名的玛利亚奇歌曲响起了。玛丽露开始大声跟着唱。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[西班牙语演唱]
The lyrics were pretty on the nose. "Beautiful and beloved Mexico, if I die far from you, let them say that I'm asleep and have them bring me back here."
歌词非常直白。“美丽的墨西哥，我心爱的祖国，如果我死在离你很远的地方，请告诉人们我在熟睡，并请让他们把我带回这里。”
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[西班牙语演唱]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The MC at the church gives an update. The buses with everyone's parents are just minutes away. Marilu suddenly gets quiet. Tears are running down her face. She lets out a sigh.
教堂的主持人提供了最新消息。载着家长们的大巴只需几分钟就到了。玛丽露突然安静下来。泪水顺着她的脸庞流下。她叹了口气。
[SIGH]
[叹气]
Daniel wipes his eyes, too. Outside, the bus pulls up in front of the church.
丹尼尔也擦了擦眼睛。外面，大巴在教堂前停下。
As they drove to the church, the parents were looking out the windows, commenting on how drab and ugly Chicago is. Well, it isn't beautiful, one of them said to me. But once we parked, everyone got very excited. Lupita says, I'm going to spring to hug them, to greet them.
在大巴开往教堂时，家长们看着窗外，评价着芝加哥是多么沉闷难看。好吧，它并不美，其中一个人对我说。但我们一停下，每个人都非常兴奋。卢皮塔说，我要跳过去拥抱他们，去迎接他们。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
She's the last parent off the bus. She enters the church building and wades into this intense scene, with little pods of families all over the place, hugging and crying.
她是最后一个下车的家长。她走进教堂，走进了这个激烈的场景，到处都是一家人的小圈子，拥抱哭泣。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I don't want to cry.
我不想哭。
But she doesn't see her kids. It's chaotic. Finally, Marilu and Daniel walk up, each of them holding a flower. Daniel is shaking a little. They surround Lupita and start hugging.
但她没看到她的孩子。场面一片混乱。最后，玛丽露和丹尼尔走过来，每人手里都拿着一朵花。丹尼尔有点颤抖。他们围住卢皮塔开始拥抱。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
They're saying, I'm so happy to see you. And it's my mom, my mom. Lupita says, it's so amazing to see you, my daughter. I love you.
他们说，见到你真高兴，我的妈妈，我的妈妈。卢皮塔说，见到你们太棒了，我的女儿。我爱你们。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Marilu gives her a big kiss. Then Daniel says, it's been 20 years since we saw each other. They linger and take a picture together. Lupita meets a great-grandchild, Marilu's grandson, who she's never met before. She tells him that he's so handsome.
玛丽露给了她一个大大的吻。然后丹尼尔说，我们二十年没见了。他们停留了一会儿拍了合影。卢皮塔见到了一个从未谋面的曾孙，玛丽露的孙子。她告诉他他长得真帅。
Then her kids grab her two bags, full of more than 100 hand-sewn sweaters, table linens, and scarves that Lupita has been working on for a year. They joke that they're filled with rocks. She had dreamed of eating at an American restaurant with her family. And suddenly, there she was, in Chicago, and her kids were telling her that they were going to take her out to dinner.
然后她的孩子们拿过她的两个包，里面装满了100多件卢皮塔手工缝制的毛衣、台布和围巾，这是她花了一年时间做的。他们开玩笑说包里装的是石头。她曾梦想着和家人在一家美国餐馆用餐。突然，她就在芝加哥，孩子们告诉她他们要带她出去吃晚饭。
Lupita spent three weeks with Daniel and Marilu in Chicago, and they didn't want me hanging around with a recorder, which I understood. But three days into the trip, before Lupita launched into her campaign to convince her kids to move home, Daniel sat down with me for an interview. And he told me, yeah, he knew what was coming. But I ran down the details with him anyway.
卢皮塔在芝加哥和丹尼尔、玛丽露待了三周，他们不希望我带着录音机到处晃，我理解。但在旅行的第三天，在卢皮塔发起说服孩子搬回家的运动之前，丹尼尔坐下来接受了我的采访。他告诉我，是啊，他知道会发生什么。但我还是跟他过了一遍细节。
Your mom, when we were talking about it, she was saying like, she has this whole plan for you. Like, she's talked to the high school principal. Maybe he's willing to hire you to teach English.
当你妈跟我聊的时候，她说她有一个完整的计划。比如，她和校长谈过了。也许他愿意雇你教英语。
[LAUGHS] I don't know if that's good. That's my mom's dream, not mine.
[笑] 我不知道那好不好。那是妈妈的梦想，不是我的。
Daniel is single with no kids, something his mom constantly reminds him.
丹尼尔单身没孩子，这事儿他妈妈总是提醒他。
She's trying to arrange things so that she has a perfect place for you. She wants to find you a woman for you to marry. She said you can live in the same house.
她正试图安排事情，好给她自己留个完美的地方给你。她想找个女人给你结婚。她说你们可以住同一所房子。
Oh yeah, she's been finding candidates for that. I'm like, no, this isn't going to work at all because I don't know how to say this, but fortunately, or unfortunately, I have absorbed so much stuff from this culture. And when I talk to people from Mexico, they're like, what he's talking about?
噢是的，她一直在找人选。我心想，不，这根本行不通，因为……我不知道怎么说，但幸运的是，或者不幸的是，我已经吸收了太多这种文化的东西。当我跟墨西哥人聊天时，他们会觉得，他在说什么？
Marilu had a different take. She wants to move back to Mexico, but not right now, not for 10 more years. She says she has to earn more money first.
玛丽露有不同的看法。她想搬回墨西哥，但不是现在，未来10年都不行。她说她必须先多挣点钱。
I think nothing Marilu and Daniel told us would have been a surprise to Lupita. Lupita knew it would be a hard sell. But she'd convinced herself that she could pull it off.
我想玛丽露和丹尼尔告诉我们的任何事情都不会让卢皮塔感到惊讶。卢皮塔知道这会是一场艰难的说服。但她已经说服自己，她能做到。
Across Mexico, kids from this generation are coming back voluntarily. Mexico has become a wealthier country in the years since they left. Some of those kids are moving back and starting businesses. Others are retiring, spending more time with family back home. They did what they came to do. I called Lupita after the trip to find out what happened.
在墨西哥各地，这一代的孩子们正在自愿回家。自从他们离开后，墨西哥已经变成了一个更富裕的国家。有些孩子正搬回去开始创业。另一些人正在退休，花更多时间陪伴国内的家人。他们实现了当初的目标。我在旅行后给卢皮塔打了电话，想看看发生了什么。
Did you stick to your plan about how you were going to ask and how many times you were going to ask?
你坚持你关于如何询问以及询问多少次的计划了吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Well, I planned it out, and I did it, but well, it didn't work.
好吧，我制定了计划，我也照做了，但好吧，没成功。
How many times did you try?
你试了多少次？
Oh, heaven, almost every other day, I'd say something to them.
噢，天哪，几乎每隔一天，我就会跟他们说点什么。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Every other day.
每隔一天。
Every third day.
每三天一次。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Yes, every other day, so that I wouldn't bother them. If not, I was going to annoy them.
是的，每隔一天，这样我就不会烦他们。要不然，我会惹恼他们的。
She ran the lines that she rehearsed. But her kids had their own response ready. They reminded her that her visa was good for 10 years, that it would be easier for her to visit them.
她演练了她排练过的台词。但她的孩子们已经准备好了回应。他们提醒她，她的签证有效期是10年，以后她来探望他们会更容易。
Did you feel disappointed? Were you surprised by what they said?
你感到失望吗？他们说的话让你感到惊讶吗？
Desperate. Desperate and sad. Sad at the same time because I said to myself, my God, I think my kids are going to stay there. So when it's my time to go, what's going to happen? They said, our lives are here. Mom, let's not talk about that right now because we're happy, and that will make us sad.
绝望。绝望而难过。同时也很悲伤，因为我对自己说，我的上帝，我想我的孩子们会待在那儿。所以等我该走的时候，会发生什么呢？他们说，我们的生活在这儿。妈，现在别谈那个了，因为我们很开心，谈那个会让我们难过。
She says that's when she understood that their answer was definite, unchangeable. She stopped bothering them about it. She wanted the reunion to remain pleasant. But the truth is there were moments when she became really sad, like when her daughter was at work and she was alone in the house. She kept that feeling to herself.
她说那就是她明白他们的回答是明确、无法改变的时候。她不再因为这事烦他们。她希望重聚能保持愉快。但事实是，有些时刻她变得非常难过，比如女儿去上班时，她一个人在屋里。她把那种感觉留在了心里。
Back in the '90s, millions of Mexican parents watched their kids leave for the US, often with just a backpack and an address. The parents never imagined that the next trips would be theirs to make, elderly moms and dads with 10-year visas, convinced by their kids that it was their turn to cross the border. Like Lupita, she'll be flying back to see her kids now and then.
回到90年代，数百万墨西哥父母看着孩子带着背包和地址前往美国。父母们从没想过下一次旅行会是他们的——带着10年签证的老年父母，被孩子们说服现在轮到他们越过边境了。像卢皮塔，她现在会不时飞过去探望孩子。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
They beat me, she said. I'm not going to say anything more about it.
他们赢了，她说。我不会再提那事了。
Kevin Sieff, he's the Mexico Bureau Chief for The Washington Post.
凯文·西夫，《华盛顿邮报》墨西哥分社社长。
[MUSIC - "TOO CLOSE TO HOME" BY RHONDA FUNK]
[音乐 - 隆达·芬克的《太亲近家了》]
Our program was produced today by Sean Cole. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Whitney Dangerfield, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Seth Lind, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Gabriela Munoz, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Dr. Vaile Wright, Virangna Kaul, Jaya Saxena, Philip Good, and Bernadette Mayer.
今天的节目由肖恩·科尔制作。负责今天节目的成员包括Bim Adewunmi、Elna Baker、Emanuele Berry、Susan Burton、Zoe Chace、Dana Chivvis、Andrea Lopez Cruzado、Whitney Dangerfield、Damien Graef、Michelle Harris、Seth Lind、Jessica Lussenhop、Miki Meek、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Gabriela Munoz、Ben Phelan、Nadia Reiman、Alissa Shipp、Lilly Sullivan、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney和Nancy Updike。我们的总编辑是Diane Wu。我们的执行编辑是David Kestenbaum。今天特别感谢Vaile Wright医生、Virangna Kaul、Jaya Saxena、Philip Good和Bernadette Mayer。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of nearly 700 episodes. Also, there's videos and tons of other stuff there. Or get our app, which has all that stuff and also lets you download as many episodes as you want. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，您可以从那里在线收听我们近700集节目的归档。网站上还有视频和海量其他内容。或者下载我们的APP，里面有所有这些内容，并且支持您下载任意多集节目。再次重申，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He told me that he bought me a Hanukkah gift this year on his trip to Mexico. I asked him what it is. He was very vague.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台（PRX）分发至各公共广播电台。一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他告诉我，他今年去墨西哥旅行时给我买了一份光明节礼物。我问他是什么。他支支吾吾。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。